[Musica]
voglio raccontarvi la storia di due
bambini da qui gli adulti si aspettavano
grandi cose nella prima storia troviamo
un bambino verso cui il padre nutriva
grandissimi aspettative
voleva che diventasse grande e forte che
eccellesse a scuola e negli sport che
diventasse un vero uomo uno tosto come
quei cowboy che si vedono nei film
western perché non hanno mai paura di
niente pensate che gli aveva persino
voluto dare il nome di uno di questi
crescendo però il bambino diventa tutto
l'opposto timido introverso iniziato a
odiare gli sport non era bravo e non gli
piacevano non era come tutti gli altri
bambini della sua età e suo padre è
estremamente deluso per questo la cosa
lo disturba cosi tanto da iniziare a boo
liz hurley lo chiama con appellativi
sminuenti offensivi lo denigra
paragonandolo alle sue sorelle lo umilia
anche in pubblico costantemente
facendolo sentire diverso ma soprattutto
sbagliato una vera delusione nella
seconda storia invece troviamo una
bambina anche gli adulti nella vita di
questa bambina si aspettavano delle cose
da lei le sue maestre delle scuole
elementari per esempio si aspettavano
che fosse una brava studentessa attenta
e studiosa come tutti i suoi compagni ma
la bambina
anche qua si rivela essere tutto
l'opposto ha serie difficoltà a
concentrarsi riesce a passare ore e ore
con lo sguardo perso nel vuoto sognando
ad occhi aperti ed estraniandosi
completamente dal mondo circostante
anche lei non era come tutti gli altri
bambini della sua classe e questo urta
profondamente le sue maestre che infatti
poco a poco iniziano anche in questo
caso a bolli ciarla iniziano a sminuirla
denigrarla a ridere rumorosamente di lei
incitando il resto della classe a fare
lo stesso iniziano anche ad escluderla
da sempre più attività scolastiche
la costringono a stare con le braccia
incrociate sul banco mentre tutti gli
altri si divertono nelle ore di
ricreazione o preparandola città di
natale tutti insieme istruendo tutti di
ignorarla se per caso avesse provato a
partecipare spesso la costringono
direttamente ad uscire dall'aula
facendole passare ore nel corridoio da
sole anche in questo caso facendola
sentire diversa esclusa ma soprattutto
sbagliata una vera delusione adesso vi
svelo un segreto
la prima storia che vi ho raccontato e
parte dell'infanzia traumatica di un
noto serial killer john wayne gacy
quello che si travestiva da clown per
intenderci la seconda storia invece è
parte della mia infanzia
nel corso del mio lavoro mi è capitato
molte volte di raccontare la storia di
questi famosi serial killer che sono
conosciuti come gli uomini più crudeli
della storia e spesso ci si chiede che
cosa ne portate ad uccidere perché la
loro vita ha preso una piega così
drammatica
durante le mie ricerche ho notato che
c'è una cosa che li accomuna tutti ma
proprio tutti ed è sempre la stessa
tutti hanno avuto un'infanzia terribile
alcuni di più alcuni di meno ma tutti
nello specifico sono stati bulli dati ci
si potrebbe aspettare forse che quelli
che da grandi diventano feroci assassini
da piccoli possano essere stati loro i
bulli invece sorprendentemente è
praticamente sempre il contrario loro
erano le vittime e bandi forse il più
famoso serial killer di tutti i tempi
veniva utilizzato scuola richard ramirez
uno dei più crudeli e diabolici uomini
mai esistiti bulli dato scuola jeffrey
dahmer che uccideva è addirittura
mangiava le sue vittime anche lui
utilizzato scuole
il più delle volte questi famosi
assassini erano vittime di adulti
venivano bulli dati proprio da quegli
adulti che avrebbero dovuto proteggerli
ma che invece
hanno fatto altro che
spegnere in loro la scintilla sapete
quella scintilla quella fiammella che
abbiamo tutti dentro che brucia e ci
spinge a vivere a usare a rialzarci ad
avere coraggio ad essere noi stessi
da grandi è nostra responsabilità a
prenderci cura della nostra fiamma
alimentarla proteggerla è nostra
responsabilità e non lasciare che si
spenga ma da bambini non possiamo non
abbiamo gli strumenti per alimentarla
non sappiamo come si fa
dobbiamo necessariamente
affidarla agli adulti di riferimento
quindi i genitori nonni insegnanti
finché non impariamo a farlo da soli ma
cosa succede se questa scintilla si
spende per che alcune vittime di
bullismo ad un certo punto scelgono la
strada della criminalità e della
violenza mentre altri seppure con un
vissuto simile invece no le domande che
cosa rende tizio un serial killer serial
killer si nasce o si diventa sono
domande che possono avere mille risposte
ma ad oggi nessuno ha saputo rispondere
con certezza è d'altronde questa non è
nemmeno la sede per parlarne in modo
professionale perché io non sono una
psicologa quello che posso fare però e
condividere con voi la mia di storia
come sono riuscita a riaccendere la mia
di fiamma quelli di voi che mi conoscono
già sapranno che sono solita raccontare
sempre storie di altre persone
ma oggi invece per cambiare vi parlo di
una parte della mia che fortunatamente
non è drammatica come le storie di
alcuni serial killer ma ricordate il
trauma è soggettivo un episodio può
essere percepito in modi diversi da
persone diverse un avvenimento che per
qualcuno è insignificante poi invece
segnare e rovinare la vita di un altro e
questo è molto importante da ricordare
perché bisogna sempre rispettare la
diversa percezione che le persone hanno
riguardo gli eventi della vita
per cinque lunghi anni gli anni delle
scuole elementari appunto sono stata
bulli data dalle mie maestre
una in particolare
io ero piccola fragile sono sempre stata
molto timida non ho mai avuto il
coraggio di risponderle né per molti
anni di raccontarlo ai miei genitori e
il motivo di tale trattamento era
semplicemente che io fossi diversa dai
miei compagni mi distraevo di più in
alcune materie soprattutto mi perdevo mi
chiudevo troppo facilmente nel mio mondo
che era sicuramente più divertente di
tutto quello che c'era da fuori era
l'unico modo che conoscessi per
difenderli per proteggermi
capisco solo oggi che tentava
disperatamente di proteggere la mia
scintilla che quelle persone volevano
per forza spegnere o cambiare
trovo che la società troppo spesso ci
voglia cambiare ci vuole tutti uguali la
scuola ci vuole tutti uguali ci insegna
fin da bambini che se non facciamo le
cose come tutti i nostri compagni
prendere un bel voto stare seduti
composti alzare la mano per chiedere il
permesso allora non valiamo se invece
fai il bravo
secondo quello che per loro è fare il
bravo allora vali semplice ci insegnano
che il nostro valore è direttamente
proporzionale al nostro modo di
performare nel mondo
ma quanto è davvero così il nostro è un
sistema prevalentemente
standardizzato dove si tende troppo
facilmente a sopprimere le disposizioni
personali
e davvero così giusto che un bambino è
costretto a cambiare a modellarsi per
adattarsi all'ambiente circostante
non sarebbe meglio se fossero proprio le
persone di riferimento
la vita di un bambino ad adattarsi alle
diversità degli individui e li
guidassero propriamente in questo
percorso
pensate per esempio ai bambini
iperattivi e sa quante volte vengono
facilmente etichettati come rompiscatole
e probabilmente puniti perché non capaci
di stare seduti fermi per ore su una
sedia come invece riescono a fare tutti
i loro compagni
quante volte viene invece considerato
che magari quel bambino soffre di
disturbo da deficit dell'attenzione
dell'iperattività estate al quarto può
sentirsi sbagliato escluso e deludente
un bambino trattato in questo modo che
non vuole rompere le scatole
ha solo bisogno di muoversi di più
rispetto agli altri e come questo ci
sono anche tantissimi altri disturbi
dell'apprendimento del comportamento nei
bambini che ancora oggi vengono ignorati
e scambiati invece per i drizia
svogliatezza e condannati con la
famigerata frase per esempio alle
potenzialità ma non si impegna e pigro e
svogliato ma non è così non esistono
bambini pigri o sbagliati tutti noi
soprattutto da bambini facciamo
semplicemente il massimo che siamo in
grado di fare in quel momento se solo
fossimo in grado di fare di più lo
faremmo quindi immaginate come possa
sentirsi un bambino che prova a fare
tutto quello che può versare per esempio
fermo sulla sedia o per adattarsi alle
aspettative della sua maestra dei suoi
genitori
nonostante queste aspettative vadano in
estremo contrasto con i suoi bisogni per
poi magari sentirsi dire frasi come sei
in punizione
niente giocattoli per te non te li
meriti non hai fatto il bravo
colpevolizzare i bambini punirli
semplicemente per il loro modo di essere
di esistere nel mondo può avere danni
gravissimi sulla loro personalità sul
loro sviluppo
e se fatto in maniera impropria può
creare in loro una graduale perdita
dell'autostima e una profonda
insicurezza proprio tutti quei
sentimenti che ci portiamo poi dentro
crescendo che se alimentati piano piano
spegneranno la nostra fiamma
io ci ho messo anni di terapia per
capire davvero che non fossi io quella
sbagliata che non avessi mai fatto
niente di sbagliato
la verità è che è impossibile per un
bambino di quell'età sbagliare o anche
solo avere gli strumenti per capire che
cosa sia giusto che cosa sia sbagliato
perché a quell'età non fa altro che
ripetere e limitare i comportamenti che
lo circonda proprio per questo vorrei
porre l'attenzione su un tema che a mio
avviso non viene ancora oggi affrontato
abbastanza ovvero la salute mentale dei
più piccoli un tema cui abbiamo iniziato
a dare attenzione solo negli ultimi anni
in italia ma che viene ancora oggi visto
come un tabù un qualcosa di cui quasi
vergognarsi viviamo la salute fisica
come una priorità mentre il benessere
mentale viene ancora percepito come una
frivolezza un'opzione quando invece è
proprio quello che mantiene viva quella
fiamma che ci brucia dentro la mia
rischiato di spegnersi molte volte ogni
volta che mi colpevolizzava per non
essere come gli altri si aspettavano che
fossi ogni volta che non riuscivo a
sentirmi a mio agio in situazioni
sociali in cui la maggior parte dei miei
coetanei invece ci si sentiva è stato
proprio quando ribaltato il mio modo di
vedere le cose che anche la mia vita ha
iniziato a cambiare quando ho deciso di
accogliere le mie stranezze e farne un
punto di forza
questo discorso quindi voglio rivolgerlo
a tutti gli adulti ma è in realtà
dedicato a tutti i bambini che sono il
fuoco del nostro futuro
prendetevi cura del vostro fuoco
prendetevi cura del fuoco dei vostri
bambini e non permettete mai che la loro
fiamma si spenga
non permettete che abbiano paura di
essere estranei celebrate le diversità
ma soprattutto non lasciate che
diventino dei serial killer
sto scherzando
oppure no